has there ever been a time when Apple
didn't say that pre-orders were
fantastic and super strong so yes in
fact a year ago apple said orders were
fantastic and super strong but they gave
us a number they said between four and
six million phones were sold over the
course of the initial weekend these
orders were taken so a lot of people
were sitting around waiting for this
number today say what's the number going
to be exactly how many phones did you
sell apple will you tell us they didn't
tell us they said super strong were
strong as what they told Bloomberg News
but they did not give us a hard number
and so you have all kinds of people
across the wall street analysts and and
Beyond trying to figure out just what
this phone would do and I think one of
the clues one of the most important
clues is the map is where they're
selling this phone where they're
offering this phone for sale yes and
there's a lot of excitement about the
new iphone 6s and the 6s plus but with
some minor tweaks i'll call them to both
software and hardware but i think the
most interesting thing about the way
they're selling this phone is where are
there selling it if you look at the
global map the biggest difference is
that this time Apple has decided to sell
this phone in China on day one it took
pre-orders in China over the course the
weekend and on day one when this phone
ships in September 25 when you look at
that map the biggest difference this
year is that is for sale in China so
it's not even a like-for-like comparison
although the first rule of writing for
Bloomberg Television a scarlet notices
don't use additives just give us the
number I'm sorry I said super strong I'm
just as strong just on just are just
better yet a number a number will tell
the story but Corey I do have an actual
question what are you learning from
suppliers about how strong the shipments
for this new phone might be so I think
one of the most important things really
is going to be actually about the the
sort of what they did last time how is
going to compare this time if you look
at year-over-year sales growth or sorry
the dependence they had in China in
particular grew dramatically when the
iphone 6 plus and 6s o released they
were growing in China to be sure but the
company's reliance on sales into China
in fact became you know well over twenty
percent of sales in the most recent
quarter and the year-over-year sales
growth also fantastic for this company
looking you know the thirty five percent
year-over-year sales the problem is can
they top that our company where
near that wall street's expecting a
twenty percent growth more or less in in
the fourth quarter in terms of sales
overall but it looks like sales of this
iphone be closer to single-digit growth
year-over-year so they're definitely in
a tough spot meeting those very strong
estimates from the analysts on Wall
Street Cory gene munster a piper jaffray
putting out a note following the release
of examples description of strong order
saying that we believe pre-orders are
indication of demand certainly but it
really reflects or is driven more by
production than anything else which
makes it difficult to actually figure
out demand yeah what do we know about
the production of the iphone this time
around so i love me some gene munster
great analysts is really good but just
last week he said if they don't give us
the number on Monday it's a sign of the
numbers not going to be bigger but in
his note out a few hours ago he said the
number is going to be bigger even though
they didn't give us that number so I
he's absolutely right that that it is
production constrained in the beginning
and it makes it hard to figure out what
the demand constraints are going to be
into the fourth quarter making that
fourth quarter even more crucial for
Apple but selling that phone in China on
the first day and in the third quarter
of the 3rd calendar quarter is going to
be a benefit to Apple i think that one
that people might not have been counting
on initially but the fourth quarters
gonna be a great big mystery